así que para esto vamos a invitar
justamente a marko calvache para
presentarnos las emociones y la
construcción del legado no estamos
hablando de terrenos de casas de ese
tipo de cosas sino algo bastante más
profundo
así que marco calvache nos va a explicar
bastante más sobre este tema él es un
apasionado del marketing con más de 14
años de experiencia como consultor de
empresas nacionales e internacionales
además de ser capacitador de más de 8000
personas en áreas como comportamiento
del consumidor
insights motivación liderazgo y
marketing estratégico las emociones y
las acciones que realizamos todos los
días son importantes para este legado
vamos a aprender un poco más con marko
bienvenido
[Aplausos]
buenos días con todos
gracias por invitación vamos a hablar de
algo que es muy importante y que son
palabras que se pueden juntar y a veces
se pueden confundir experiencia y
trascendencia
la experiencia lógicamente desde el
presente nos han hablado mucho acerca de
cómo tenemos que manejar una experiencia
inolvidable y muy buena para un cliente
un paciente alguna persona pero qué es
la trascendencia la trascendencia tiene
que ver con el futuro y hablar de
trascender es algo mucho más importante
pero parte desde las emociones
seguramente ustedes han escuchado el
triángulo de la vida si pasaron
terremoto horita dios no quiera todos
sabrían cómo ocultarse en el triángulo
de la vida sino sin embargo yo les voy a
hablar ahora sobre el nuevo triángulo de
la vida que es para que puedas
trascender y es el siguiente primero
aquí después aquí y después aquí qué
significa eso primero tengo que partir
de las emociones una vez que ya trabajo
bien las emociones ya no podré salir de
la mente de alguien y después
esto qué significa que lo tendré en el
bolsillo será mi ojo será para futuro
para sí como comenzamos esto hablando de
una pequeña historia que ustedes todo el
mundo la conocen y relacionado al fútbol
pero les va a contar desde mi
perspectiva cómo pasó esto yo tengo dos
hijos y mi primer hijo de dos años
cuando cumplía dos años en contra lo que
dijo mi mamá mi suegra y mi esposa les
llevé al estadio a verle a mi equipo
favorito me dijeron que era entre
irresponsable salvaje que un imprudente
que como voy a exponer al pobre niño a
eso ya mí no me importó y lo llevé
calladito lógicamente y le hice pasar
toda la experiencia le compren su
uniforme chiquitito le compre su peluche
le compre la comidita típica y el
estadio cuando estuvo sentado en las
gradas le dije lógicamente tenía dos
años no le dije hijo mío este es el
equipo de tus sueños
no tienes que rendirle pleitesía
devoción amor por el resto de tu vida
y pobre de ti que te cambios a
otro equipo
ojo para muchos puede sonar este abrupto
ridículo pre para mí no
pero lo que les invito a pensar ahora es
no que hice sino el por qué lo hice lo
importante es entender que tuvo que
hacer ese equipo o tu equipo en ti aquí
para que tú sientas la obligación y el
deber de heredarle esa marca a tus hijos
y la pregunta es de dónde parte es o
específicamente de las emociones
y para nosotros manejar las emociones y
querer trascender a futuro necesitamos
entender los códigos y los códigos son
esos lenguajes que nos permiten a
nosotros saber cómo nos entendemos pero
el problema de las emociones es que
nosotros asumimos mucho y los códigos
son diferentes y para ponerles un
ejemplo muy simpático los hombres y las
mujeres tenemos códigos diferentes
fallamos porque porque emocionalmente
nosotros los hombres pensamos que las
mujeres piensan como nosotros y tiene
emociones como nosotros y las mujeres
piensan lo mismo para ponerles un
ejemplo llevo 12 años de casado más o
menos a los dos meses de haberme casado
no he visto yo llegué a mi casa mi
esposa ya había llegado a su trabajo yo
llegué feliz
y mi esposa con la mano a la pena viendo
la tele si él digo hola cómo estás y sin
regresar me ver contestó bien
como el hombre es curioso y no se puede
quedar con nada agarra y le pregunté a
mi vida qué te pasa y sin regresarme a
ver con la misma posición nada
como el hombre es literal nada es nada
fui a hacer lo mío regresé y estaba con
una sonrisa de oreja a oreja y me siento
y ella ya tenía una lágrima ocurrida el
rímel en la misma posición y hago la
pregunta más ridícula que alguien podría
haber hecho en ese momento no que no te
pasaba nada
apocalypse capítulo unos señores me
mandó a donde ustedes no se imaginan me
dijo que era un insensible que no tenía
sentimientos y mientras ella me estaba
mandando al demonio yo decía como rayos
llegué aquí
lo que entendí en ese momento es que yo
no estaba entendiendo el código de mi
esposa 12 años después
ella me dice no me pasa nada y lo que
realmente quiere decirme es algo similar
a algo me pasa espera que te cuente y si
es mi familia ni te metas
de entender ese código de mi esposa e
incluso ahora me acerco y les digo qué
te pasa nada
cuéntame
a veces llora a besos le digo mi amor
quieres que me vaya si por favor no
quiero ni ver te entendí su código y
comenzamos a entendernos valga la
redundancia emocionalmente 2
hay un código muy chévere y cultural de
nosotros como seres humanos que hablamos
con él no es parte de nuestro código
para nosotros él no es si solo fíjense
oye te queda bien este color sí no
no sabes que mañana me caso no te puedo
creer o sabes que fulano acaba de
conseguir un empleo no te creo él no es
parte de nuestra vida es más los seres
humanos los hombres principalmente en
las observaciones que hemos visto los
hombres no procesamos el no vemos un no
tocar
y automáticamente tocamos
y uno de los códigos que nos permite
emocionalmente entender nuestra forma es
que somos extremadamente negativos y
aquí damas y caballeros les invito a
hacer un pequeño experimento social pero
ojo bajo su responsabilidad van a
agarrar su teléfono y le van a mandar el
siguiente mensaje de texto a su pareja
mamá amigo amante nadie juzga lo que le
van a mandar siguiente mensaje de texto
y van a poner
tenemos que hablar 3 puntos suspensivos
enviar está comprobado
está comprobado que una persona que
decir ese mensaje como tenemos un código
negativo no puede con incertidumbre y va
a ver el mensaje va a decir jesús del
gran poder madre de dios que habrá
pasado en algunos casos me casaron
pero aquí viene el ejercicio la persona
recibe el mensaje y te va a llamar y
está comprobado los ejercicios que hemos
hecho que una persona que recibe ese
mensaje te va a tratar de contactar al
menos cuatro veces pero tú no le van a
contestar
al tercero a cuarto llamada o un mensaje
de texto que tú no contestas tú le vas a
llamar y esto le va a dar cierta
tranquilidad y el trato que conteste vas
a apagar el teléfono y lo vas a sacar la
batería durante tres horas que creen que
va a pasar bueno les cuento el caso más
simpático fue hace aproximadamente unos
ocho años mismo ejercicio dos días de
capacitación una charla similar a esta
final del primer día y un chico al
frente me dice yo qué va a hacer con mi
novia digo fantástico cómo te llamas
pancho como se llama tu novia jessica
tienes mensajes y escribir y tenemos que
hablar 3 puntos suspensivos de enviar a
los dos segundos con mayúsculas de
signos de admiración interrogación la
novia escribió que pasó dije no le
contesté es esta chica un poco intensa
le trató de contactar 11 veces ya le vi
que se puso nervioso le dije tiene
saldos y llámale que sepa que eres tú y
el rato que conteste me pasó el teléfono
a lo mi vida que agarré el teléfono de
pago y pancho pacto de caballeros vas a
sacar la batería y le vas a poner
nuevamente en tres horas y mañana nos
cuentas qué pasó
cerramos del tacto con un apretón de
manos y nos fuimos al otro día llegaron
todos
era lógico porque porque ya cuando contó
nos dijo que la novia le había estado
buscando hasta en la morgue damas
caballeros somos y tenemos un código
emocional negativo somos seres
emocionales y para poder trascender
tenemos que partir de las emociones las
emociones fuertes trascienden y para eso
necesitamos verdades absolutas la
primera nada es obvio yo no puedo asumir
lo que te emociona ti quizás la emoción
a mí lo que a ti te llama la atención
quizás no me llama la atención a mí lo
que a ti te funciona quizás no me
funciona a mí lo que pasó ayer o lo que
funcionó ayer quizás no funcione hoy lo
que funciona aquí en ecuador que éstas
no funcionen colombiano en europa no
podemos asumir y en el plano emocional
menos aún imagínense si los códigos son
tan diferentes asumir nos puede tener
una gran cantidad de problemas
emocionales y hasta cierto punto de
códigos estuve en chile hace un par de
años dando una charla un grupo de
empresarios y estaba explicándoles con
una pequeña curva tipo
electrocardiograma de venta se les decía
miren aquí en julio y en enero tenemos
unos picos muy importantes y jajaja
yo todos los auditorios yo me quedé frío
y le dije bueno de qué se ríen y alguien
al frente me dijo es que dijiste pico yo
digo en el que significa pico a quien
chile antes de decir lo que significa
pico en chile damas y caballeros que
significa pico aquí en ecuador pico aquí
en ecuador es la boca de la botella pico
aquí a cuadros es un besito pico aquí
también es lo que tienen los pájaros
para comer pico es sinónimo de punta
décima pico incluso es una herramienta
que nos ayuda a sacar las cosas del piso
saben lo que significa pico el chin y el
chile por favor haga no se den asiento
pico en chile significa pene y de la
peor forma que lo puedo decir yo les
decía acá tenemos un restaurante que se
llama aplicó el rico imagínate
nadie lo vio 2
siempre tienes audiencia tu gente te
está viendo y emocionalmente conectado
desconectas el rato que tú entiendes que
siempre tienes audiencia tú tienes que
manejar las emociones exactas los niños
tu gente la gente que consume o los que
están cerca a ti te están observando y
aprenden en función de las emociones si
tú sabes que siempre tienes audiencia
vas a poder manejar mejor ese escenario
y ojo el hecho de que me guste algo a mí
no garantiza que me gusten todas las
versiones de ese algo solo vamos al caso
del ágil a todo el mundo le gusta elegir
quizás sí pero a mí no me gusta todas
las versiones de la he elegí su hábito
para mí no sé si necesito es súper
fuerte picante y si yo busca esa emoción
relacionado con cualquier producto
sensación voy a buscar eso no me vas a
convencer con ají suave o un ají que no
me va a picar necesitamos ahondar más
allá y lo más importante información la
información es poder antes
si alguien tenía tierras o tenía
propiedades tiene poder hoy que tiene
información y sabe cómo usarla tiene
poder hicimos una investigación desde
investigación de mercados a más de 1000
observaciones a hombres y mujeres
millennials entre 18 a 34 años en
consumo de shampoo como sus emociones
podían influir sus consumos y
determinamos que eran totalmente
diferentes primero después de estas
observaciones vimos que los hombres se
demoraban aproximadamente 14 segundos en
comprar shampoo
como compra hombre un shampoo observamos
agarrar su carrito de compras
comprados
14 segundos que significa que habemos
hombres que nos demoramos menos de 14
segundos y hay hombres que demoran más
de 14 segundos les preguntamos qué es lo
que valoran en un shampoo y nos dijeron
tres cosas pero no este orden que me
limpie la caspa que lógicamente se
abarató y la espuma y la espuma es un
factor emocional tan fuerte porque
porque fuimos hacia atrás a entender
cómo es el proceso de baño en un hombre
y determinamos que se demoraban en
nuestro estudio entre 5 y 7 minutos y el
baño es una experiencia lúdica mientras
manejamos y estamos alegres mientras más
sensación de espuma mejor lavado y si
estoy feliz y tanto negó la bobina hable
hombres de las nieves
57 minutos 14 segundos en compra ahora
qué pasa con las mujeres
ya podrán imaginarse las mujeres se
demoran en nuestro estudio dos minutos
con dos segundos en promedio eso
significa que hay mujeres que demoran
más de dos minutos y mujeres que se
demoran menos de dos minutos como compra
una mujer el shampoo agarra su carrito
de compras entra ubica la percha suelta
el carro y se pone así
el shampoo
abre huele algunos se ponen otras se
roban
preguntamos
en qué puesto creen que estaba la espuma
ni asomaban los primeros ellos que
crecían en ellas el brillo el olor que
el cabello quede como simba una gran
cantidad de cosas particularmente del
uso de champú y fuimos atrás a ver
cuánto tiempo se bañaban entre 17 y 23
minutos y cuidado si es que hay 15
y mientras el hombre tiene una
experiencia lúdica a veces la mujer no
tiene una experiencia lúdica en ese
elemento sino es un ritual de belleza
que a veces es aburrido con otras partes
no tan emocional el momento que nosotros
entendemos esa información podemos
trascender y más que nada los cuatro
puntos claves para la trascendencia
entender las emociones de hoy
y qué emoción quiero yo transmitir a mi
gente a mis hijos a la gente que nos va
a ver a futuro 2 el tiempo cuánto tiempo
le dedico a crear y a desarrollar estas
emociones porque el tiempo es un
determinante hablamos de los hábitos
hace un momento es lógicamente
emocionalmente tenemos que llegar a eso
siguiente la historia por algo el doctor
te pide tu historia clínica porque todo
lo que te ha pasado te hace lo que eres
hoy emocionalmente emocionalmente pasa
exactamente lo mismo y finalmente el
conocimiento
necesitamos conocer necesitamos ir un
poco más allá porque el rato que tenemos
la información tenemos poder no nos
olvidemos de ellos ellos están viendo
todo lo que hacemos están viendo todo lo
que percibimos y como nuestras emociones
son evaluadas y desarrolladas a diario
ellos van a imitar mucho de eso futuro
por eso no tenemos que desacreditar
nuestros rituales nuestros pensamientos
a quienes adoramos oa quienes amamos
porque porque emocionalmente están
conectados no te olvides de que el rato
de que tú crees algo cualquier producto
o servicio
cualquier cosa partes de lo emocional
primero aquí segundo aquí y después de
aquí crea productos en cambio los
hábitos de las personas y también crean
soluciones que cambien sus creencias
muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]